[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
e
inquiet - ce que tu souhaites qu'elle
peut soit on veut le dieu dragon
exaucera d'après guerre
je veux un xbox 360 attendant ministre
s'en sortent avec des femmes ou 90 comme
le minix dans les trente trois années où
il pèse 3 allée ok ok j'ai décidé madame
ont joué le jeu veulent pas d'une partie
dans le golfe younès mais quoi pourquoi
tu mets un peu plus tôt on veut et
maintenant exaucé je dois me retirer
[Musique]
cours
[Rires]
[Musique]
l'univers de dragon ball c'est juste la
chose la plus énorme qui ait jamais été
inventé non mais c'est vrai franchement
qui parmi vous n'a jamais fait au moins
une fois ce geste est que ce soir à 22 h
dans le hall ball z c'était clairement
ma raison numéro 1 de me lever les joues
rouges avait pas école pour ceux qui
dormaient au fond je rappelle vite fait
c'est l'histoire de sangoku un enfant
queue de singe construit au travers de
plusieurs séries qui vont de sa petite
enfance dans dragon ball jusqu'à la fin
dans dragon ball z et il n'y a rien
après dragon ball z
rien n'est fait c'est quoi la belle
salle on fait tous des erreurs c'est
quand même fou quand même 20 ans après
il ya encore des jeux qui s'ordonne
dessus et quand je vois les budokai et
les derniers jeux sur l'univers que ce
soit dragon ball dragon ball z mais je
me rends compte que j'aurais tué à
l'époque pour pouvoir y jouer cinq
minutes après on a aussi eu des bons
jeux les plus connus à l'époque c'était
les buts audel
enfin c'était dragon ball z 1 2 et 3 sur
super nintendo
moi perso je vais la version megadrive
donc du coup quand j'ai découvert la
version super nes je t'avais tout le
temps l'un kruth chez mon voisin pour
pouvoir y jouer
[Musique]
globalement la licence dragon ball a
toujours produit des jeux de très bonne
qualité mais cela vie pour dix jeux en
moyenne sur l'univers de dragon ball qui
sortait au japon il avait à peine le
seul qui arrivé jusqu'en france
le premier jeu arriver chez nous en
france c'est celui ci dragon ball et le
secret du dragon et comme on dit la
première fois c'est toujours décevant a
jamais été aussi vrai
ce jeu ne doit pas être utilisé avec une
version mac tel ou la version nintendo
de la nintendo
ok rock merde
[Musique]
le jeu est en français c'est assez rare
pour le dire à cette époque sur nintendo
d'ailleurs si vous n'aviez pas fait le
rapprochement c'est édité par bandai y
les mêmes qui massacrent auront trois
ans plus tard les chevaliers du zodiaque
[Musique]
les balles du dragon et si seulement le
deuxième écran du jeu
le deuxième écran du jeu au coeur de
voir la suite maintenant bon partons
[Musique]
comment
les retrouver
avec sa femme
ouais bon
radars les pages du dragon bon le
principe est un peu le même que dans
zelda on voit son personnage sans vos
convives youtube et on se déplace dans
les décors dans les maisons on ramasse
des clés sauf que là contrairement à
zelda il ya aucun aspect rpg n'est pas
vendeur n'y a pas de menus objets n'y a
pas de personnage à qui parler vous
ramassez au fil de l'aventuré les mêmes
objets le bâton magique com - déjà -
votre force
la nourriture qui est jeune votre
énergie et des sortes de petites
portions blanche qui met un gros coup de
boost à sangoku en le faisant aller plus
vite
je crois que c'est du riz peut-être
peut-être de là non non non c'est dur il
se nourrit je sais que c'est un problème
récurrent dans tous les jeux que je
teste mais comme pour tous les autres il
ya forcément son lot de problèmes de
collisions et c'est pratiquement
impossible de s'avancer et de frapper sa
crosse ou le migou c'est surtout visible
quand on se bat contre les boss
particulièrement contre yamcha avec
d'autres je me touche là parler
n'importe quoi sérieux ballet va mourir
la vous avez vu ça ils à 10km de
moi ça c'est yamcha fadal siveco merde
aux fumeurs la meilleure stratégie c'est
de se encore à coire et de bruyne
et en espérant pas chromé mais le pire
là dedans c'est que quand vous sortez
des boss avait quasiment plus d'énergie
vous dites bon allez je vais y aller
mollo et faire attention il s'en veut
pas crever et maintenant votre
énergie des sables tout tout seul même
si vous faites rien pour toi dépêche-toi
les pêcheurs allaient lâcher moindre
guerre vous ferez bande de rats popu t
il à la chaîne ni tête à l'est de la
bouffe
ah non
[Musique]
vaduz a mais dragon ball c'est pas que
le corps-à-corps moi j'aimerais bien
pouvoir faire un vrai kamehameha sur la
notice j'ai vite vu qu'il fallait
maintenir b et appuyez sur a attend
c'est ça le connaît bien renault
on dirait un vieux frisbee avec une
épaule dessus voire amère rembourser
s'inscrire au point complètement
défoncée bronzé faire ça non mais
sérieusement il ya des choses avec
lesquelles faut pas plaisanter vous
n'allez pas me dire que tactiquement la
laisse est pas capable de faire un truc
aussi simple que ça les niveaux de
premier village cours et attend me dis
pas que c'est voulons
ah non mais les traducteurs non gorée
habitent ici ils n'étaient resto la conf
le gauche
c'est le goku cherche gorée
normalement dans la version originale le
jeu les cinématiques de dialogue
absolument tout était plus rapide
moi je ne suis pas en détail mais en
passant du format était assez à pâques
pour rendre le jeu compatible la vitesse
a été diminuée du coup si on regarde une
nation américaine ou japonaise c'est
plus du tout la même chose
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs en par la musique
ceci est l'unique musique que vous
entendrez dans tout ce de jeu
cette boucle de quelques secondes est
l'exemple typique de la musique qui va
tellement ce grave et profondément dans
votre cerveau que vous allez l'entendre
absolument partout
[Musique]
tiens voilà jean combes tortue géniale
ici s'appelle lhermitte
voici un cadeau en récompense bronche
pas ça doit être le nuage magique vient
nuage léger un put
et là normalement si vous avez lu le
manga vous devriez savoir quelle est la
suite
donne moi ton repas on lui doit
cacher le meilleur passage au
pour ceux qui auraient vu que le dessin
animé sans avoir lu le manga normalement
tortue géniale demanda bulma ce moment
là de lui montrer sa culotte
sauf que là visiblement la censure est
passé sur les dialogues de la version
française est résident regarder la tête
qui fait décidément je suis basque 10
mai dans ce riz mais ça a l'air bon bon
je sais qu'ils ont voulu justifier
l'aspect zelda en rentrant dans les
maisons pour fouiller mais il ya
peut-être exagération là
[Musique]
j'ai mal à la tête
olé mais regardez ça appelle
j'entre dans un bâtiment je me prends le
coup j'ai même pas le temps de réagir
quoi y'a plus de regarder je suis
beaucoup de niveaux les pieds sont
rentrés passage suis pas très au fait de
la merde et là partout ces campagnes et
en plus ça commence à me courir sur le
haricot cette histoire rigolote magique
[Musique]
si je dois le reconnaître une qualité
quand même c'est que le je suis assez
fidèlement le manga ne vendent plus mal
la rencontre avec tortue géniale ou
longue puis yamcha les maisons qui
ressemble une aide marc l'univers
laventure dans le château de pilar sans
voix au couple est parent dans l'espace
quoi mais qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont
fait son goku mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait sur la lune
qu'est ce qu'on fout sur la lune c'est
qui cette vieille regarder ça on part
sur des tuyaux en évitant des arcs
électriques pour les curieux peuvent
l'en croire il enlever son du docteur
robotnik
c'est pas aussi les études et foncez
chez bandaï je me rends très dur il
ou peut-être peut-être de là en fait
complètement défoncés pour oser
personnes ont regardé
décidément je suis pas dans ce riz mais
j'avais envie oui
ils s'étaient tous défoncés les
traductions qui semble opium temps plus
génial produits hallucinogènes et qui
voit les lacs partout la musique il ans
livre savant fou qui lance des critiques
qui valut au mieux là bas il ne me reste
plus qu'une chose à faire de supprimer
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup ri jusqu'à présent et
maintenant qui commence sérieusement à
agacer
ça n'a pas marché et pas chômé dans le
volt si ce jeu est magnifique
regarde moi ces graphismes les
cellulaires je n'ai qu'à travers tous
les meurtres énergie
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hahaha
bon cette approche prête approche
magloire
[Musique]
allez voler
et ben si
[Musique]
ouais
m
[Musique]